what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control and i wanted to give you guys an
ending guide on how to get the various
endings of eldon ring how you can
potentially mess them up which ones give
you achievements and how to make sure
you progress them properly with the game
being so long and massive it can be
frustrating to feel like you messed up
one step and have to pay for it hours
later i know because i screwed up to the
potential endings there will be spoilers
in this guide but to try and mitigate
that the best i can i'll have timestamps
in the description so you can hop to the
specific ending guide you're interested
in
there are six potential endings in eldon
ring and most are related to side quests
so
let's do this
we start with the normal ending you're
going to get the age of fracture doing
this will get you the elden lord
achievement there are multiple elden
lord endings and all this one requires
is
well nothing just touch fractured
america and choose mend the elden ring
as a caveat if you progress the lord of
frenzied flame past a certain point you
won't be able to choose any ending other
than frenzied flame
unless you complete a series of side
quests but i'll cover that in the lord
of frenzied flame section
now we get into the interesting side
quests and the age of duskborn ending
this one will also get you the elden
lord achievement so it really just
changes the ending a little and is
interesting from historian lore
perspective
this particular side quest involves
roger d
deathbed fear and dee's brother you can
actually mess up part of this side quest
to be okay but i'll still cover the
specifics to start this off speak with
roger at stormville castle afterwards
you're going to need to head down to the
secret area where you'll find a tree
spirit and the death root tree that's
spreading throughout stormville and
likely in the image of godwin
touch the bloodstain and note that it's
roger getting impaled
everything from here on out regarding
roger is interesting especially from a
lore perspective and what he'll tell you
but in regards to actually finishing the
quest don't worry if you missed it it
actually isn't necessary what is
necessary is to speak with the deathbed
companion thea to speak with her you
have to let her hold you again after she
gives you the baldicon's blessing
eventually she'll give you a weathered
dagger and ask you to return it to his
owner
this isn't dee but he knows the owner so
give it to him in a chilling scene theo
will kill d but in terms of getting the
ending don't worry this is supposed to
happen and theo will disappear
at this point you're going to have to
head into nakron the eternal city to get
here defeat radon let the meteor hit and
you'll find where the meteor struck next
to fort height within nakron you can
find an aqueduct area and for beating
the bosses be able to travel up the
waterfall behind them and into the
deeper depths find the main boss area
here and you'll have to defeat theo's
champions
don't worry about the fact that she
essentially tried to kill you walk up to
her and when you confront her choose to
side with her and say no i want to be
held this will allow you to continue her
questline she'll now ask you for the
curse mark of death to find it you'll
have to do ronnie's questline which i'll
detail in full later in the age of stars
portion of the video but to quickly talk
about that go to ronnie's tower choose
to help ronnie become the empyrean and
by going down that route and helping her
eventually she'll give you a way to
enter the divine tower of lyrnia this is
located at the karyan study hall and
she'll give you the means to access it
make it to the divine tower of lyrinia
and you'll find the curse mark of death
on her discarded body now that you have
the curse mark of death bring it back to
fia reload and then enter her dream to
fight the lich dragon forta sax
defeat him and you'll be able to get the
rune of the death prince now when you
beat the game you'll have the option to
use this on fraction america which will
yield you the age of duskborn ending
this is yet another ending that will get
you the alden lord achievement for the
age of despair you'll need to finish the
dung eaters questline what this involves
is finding a seed bed curse once you do
the dung eater phantom at the round
table hold will give you a key in order
to unlock his prison cell underneath the
royal capital of lane del
the dung uterus prison cell can be found
within the well of lane dell that you
can see me entering here
or here on a map
once you enter this well you'll
eventually reach the subterranean
shunning grounds once you've found the
underground roadside sight of grace exit
to your left or north east and head
right into the caged hole in the ground
after you drop down into the sewer and
defeat the rats you'll have an option to
leave through a pipe to your right or
through some miranda blooms on your left
head past the miranda blooms and up the
ladder at the end of this path you'll
reach the dung eater's prison cell speak
with him and as awful as it is tell him
to leave his jail
once he does head back to where the dung
uter phantom was at the roundtable hold
and you'll find a message telling you to
meet him at the outer moat this refers
to the outer moat of landel you can find
this section of the moat where he
invades just northwest of the capital
rampart's site of grace as a note if
you've been following blackguard's
storyline he'll end up here and it's
well worth doing it as it will net you
an additional seabed curse which you'll
need to fully finish this questline
defeat the dung eater's phantom here and
then return to him at the round table
hold real he'll ask you to implant his
corporeal form in the subterranean
shunning grounds with the seed bed curse
you'll now need five seed bed curses i
gave him four and then killed him
completely screwing myself out of
properly finishing this questline it's
my understanding that if you give him
less than five as long as you don't kill
him
like
i did you can always return and give him
more afterwards you'll get the mending
rune of the fel curse from him now like
the previous quest lines you'll have a
new option at fractured america allowing
you to get this ending
this is yet another ending that will get
you the alden lord achievement for the
age of order questline you'll need
brother corn and gold mask as a heads up
you can screw yourself out of this
ending this is the other one i messed up
i think the way to screw it up is by
having melanon do her event at the
mountaintops of the giants before you
progress this storyline along enough
this happened to me and i later found
brother coryn dead on the altus plateau
before i was able to properly progress
his storyline
so to do this one once you reach the
altar's plateau speak with brother corin
he'll tell you he's leaving to find gold
mask he heads to the altus plateau just
north of the altus highway junction site
of grace along the trail and where you
found the altus plateau map fragment
after speaking with him go find a gold
mask gold mess can be found on the
broken downforce spanning great bridge
all you need to do is head north to it
warp across then turn around and you'll
find gold mask at the edge staring at
the tree
speak with him even though he'll say
nothing back to you and return to
brother coryn
corrin will now move next to gold mask
so speak to both of them to progress the
storyline further which will happen
after you have two great runes you'll
now find them in lane dell the capital
city on a cliff near the coliseum after
talking with them in full you'll now
need to head to the ratigan statue in
lane dell of the capital city which can
be found after fighting godfrey the
first elden lord's phantom
in order to solve this puzzle you'll
need to obtain the spell law of
regression you can find this by
traveling out of an exit and onto the
roof of the upper level where you fought
godfrey the first elden lord's phantom
from here travel up and back into the
top level of the godfrey first elden
lord boss fight here you'll be able to
find the golden order principia prayer
book which contains the law of
regression spell within
now you'll need to travel to ratigan
statue which you can find by going down
an elevator just outside this very same
boss chamber the statue has a message in
the front that says regression alone
reveals secrets so cast law of
regression here for a major lore reveal
after the shocking discovery go chat
with brother corrin and gold mask after
this point the pair will move to the
bridge south of the stargazers runes at
the mountaintops of the giants speak
with them again here
finally you'll need to finish crumbling
pharah mozilla before you fully finish
this you'll find gold masks corpse and
lanedale ashen city near the coliseum
and containing the rune of perfect order
once again you'll need to choose to use
this rune on fractured america which
will net you the age of order ending
the fifth ending will get you the age of
star's achievement in order to do this
one you'll have to progress ronnie's
storyline the first thing you'll have to
do here is visit ronnie at ronnie's
tower located in the three sisters here
behind karia manor ronnie was the one
behind stealing the death rune mentioned
in the story trailer to eldon ring she
wants to bring about an entirely new age
so choose to help her out and don't
worry this won't lock you out of
anything else in the game it's even
required for the age of duskborn ending
to progress or storyline
once you've done this you can help out
blive or celebus and learn that the
blacksmith eg is actually her war
counselor and while all of that's
interesting none of it is actually
required of you for this ending the only
thing you'll need to do is head into
caled and defeat star scourge radon
take him out and a meteorite will strike
the lands between specifically hitting
right next to fort height use this
opening as an opportunity to travel down
and into the amazingly cool nakron the
eternal city head down here and explore
until you find the ancestral wood side
of grace located here
now if you look behind you there's
actually a set of buildings you can jump
on and explore which will lead you to
the knight's sacred ground you'll need
to fully explore here in order to find
the finger slayer blade and the next
quest item you'll need for ronnie so
return to ronnie hand her the blade and
she'll give you the karyon inverted
statue before heading off you can use
this inverted statute at the current
study hall in order to find an item
you'll need to progress the age of the
duskborn storyline
meanwhile rena's tower located within
the three sisters will have now opened
up so travel there and you'll discover a
warp that will take you right into
previously inaccessible part of einstein
river and noxtella the eternal city
thoroughly explore this and first defeat
the baleful shadow for which you'll be
rewarded a discarded palace key
next defeat astell natural born of the
void and behind him you'll find a lift
that will take you up to the moonlight
altar travel back to the rail lucario
grand library you'll need to have
defeated renault in order to access it
you're now able to open the mysterious
locked chest and within it you'll find
the darkmoon ring
now from the moonlight altar head
directly south past glenstone dragon a
doula and you'll reach the cathedral of
manistelus where you'll be able to find
ronnie give her the ring and now be able
to access the age of stars ending after
you beat the final boss you'll also get
the darkmoon greatsword eldon ring's
moonlight greysword for doing this quest
so that's pretty amazing
now when you reach fracture america
instead of choosing an option on her
choose to summon irani at her summon
sign and you'll get her ending along
with the achievement
and now the final ending lord of the
frenzied flame which will also net you
an achievement as a note this one is
extremely difficult to back out of once
you've started it so i'll both guide you
into how to unlock this ending and how
to seal it away so you can go back to
getting the other endings let's start
with unlocking the ending hayata the
blind maiden is related to this
questline but you actually don't need to
complete her quest in order to unlock
this ending
all you need to do is head into lane
dell capital city and find the well
located here
this is the same well you'll need to
enter in order to find dung eater's true
body however for this one you'll need to
fully explore the subterranean shunning
grounds if you can reach the bottom of
this underground maze you'll eventually
find moog the omen for defeating him
you'll get the cathedral of the forsaken
site of grace and melano will beg you to
turn around
please
leave the frenzied flame alone
however this instead clued me in on the
fact something was going on in this room
so hit the altar and it will reveal a
secret passage that travels even lower
under the capital and is disturbingly
filled with the bodies of those who have
gone insane
make your way to the bottom doing some
from software-esque platforming and
strip down into your undies once you're
naked you'll be able to approach the
three fingers will brand you and make
you a glowing cluster of madness
at this point you are now locked into
the lord of the frenzied flame ending
all you need to do is finish the game
and touch the fractured america you
won't even have the option to summon
ronnie
in order to undo this you'll need to
complete millicent's quest line
millicent is the plague-written woman
who's dying of scarlet rot in the
cathedral of the plague which is located
here directly east of celia town of
sorcery the first thing you'll need to
do is head to sage gallery's shack
located at the entrance to celia town of
sorcery he'll ask you to help out
millicent which requires you to find an
unalloyed gold needle you can find this
in the heart of eonia swap located here
on a map by defeating commander o'neal
return to sage gowery give him the
undeloid gold needle rest at a sight of
grace and return to him for a fixed
version of this needle
now you'll need to bring it to millicent
which will cure her temporarily of her
rotting sickness exhaust her dialogue
until she leaves the church and now head
back to gallery shack where you'll find
her once again exhaust her dialogue so
she leaves
next up you'll need to head into the
shaded castle located here on the north
side of the altus plateau within this
castle beyond a clean rot night you'll
be able to find a chest that contains
the valkyrie's prosthesis you'll need
this to continue millicent's questline
now you'll find her up on altus plateau
right by the earthry gazing hill side of
grace she'll lament that she can no
longer fight without her sword arm so
give her the valkyrie's prosthesis
next up head to dominola windmill
village where you'll need to defeat the
godskin apostle after you do this rest
at the sight of grace and you can find
millicent at dominola near the windmill
heights site of grace after chatting
with her she'll once again move now to
the mountaintops of the giants and near
the ancient snow valley runes site of
grace it's located here on a map once
again exhauster dialogue alright all of
that done it's now time to head into
nicholas haley tree to access it you'll
need to find both haley trees secret
medallions and use them at the grand
lift of rolled one of these can be found
at castle seoul in the mountaintops of
the giants where you'll need to defeat
commander nile in order to reach it the
other can be found at the village of the
albinorics you'll have to find albus the
albanoric who's hiding disguised as a
giant pot just roll into it and you'll
break the illusion after talking to him
albus will give you the other half of
the medallion finally you'll have to
solve the puzzle of ordinal liturgical
town located here on a map in order to
reach nikola's hailig tree work your way
down and at the prayer room site of
grace and alphael brace of the halo tree
you'll find millicent once again chat
with her and exhaust her dialogue
now you'll need to continue down raphael
until you reach the drainage channel
site of grace turn around head back up
into the rod infested portion of the
halo tree and you'll be able to find an
ulcerated tree spirit defeat this rest
at the drainage channel side of grace
again and return back to where the
ulcerated tree spirit was you'll now
find a summon sign to either help or
attack millicent help her to feed her
four sisters
[Music]
rest at a sight of grace return here and
exhaust her dialogue or back to the
drainage channel set of grace rest and
then return once again and you'll find
the unalloyed gold needle on her corpse
now it's time for the most difficult
challenge of the game you'll now have to
defeat melania blade of nicola i'm not
going to go too deeply on strategies to
defeat her but suffice to say this was
one of the only fights in the entire
game i actually felt the need to use a
spirit ash for most builds i'm going to
recommend getting your mimic tier ash to
plus 10 for this fight and she will
still be nail bitingly tough
once you've done it and you've conquered
melania you can now use your unalloyed
needle on melania's scarlet rot flower
to receive mykola's needle nikola's
needle as the description says is the
one thing that can quell the frenzied
flame within and thereby prevent you
from getting the lord of the frenzied
flame ending if you use it on yourself
after touching the three fingers
however
you still can't use it as it says the
needle is as yet unfinished and can only
be used in the heart of the storm beyond
time said to be found in pharah missoula
so
you'll now need to enter and fully
explore crumbling for missoula the very
last site of grace before the main boss
of the area is the beside the great
bridge side of grace from here turn
around go down the elevator exit the
building you're in head straight ahead
and drop onto the floating ledges
travel down further and lie down near
the heart of the tornado which will seem
to stop time itself and warp you into
dragon lord placid deus axes boss
chamber
and now you can finally use mikala's
needle on yourself you actually don't
need to defeat dragonlord plastidusex to
use it although defeating him does get
you a convenient side of grace warp to
quickly travel back here and use
mikala's needle when you want
as a note nicholas needle is a one-time
use item so once you use it you
permanently lock yourself out of getting
the lord of the frenzy flame ending so
if you want to get every ending and
achievement in the game i recommend save
scumming before using the needle and
then going from there
and there you go a guide to how to get
every ending in elden ring i hope this
helped and make sure to stick to
gamespot for more on elden ring we
already have plenty of guys and other
mechanics around the game and i'll be
working hard to bring you in-depth lore
on alden ring coming soon in line with
my previous souls lore videos i've made
over the years thanks so much and i'll
see you guys next time
peace
[Music]
you